okay hello everyone welcome to another
wolfram language design review part of
our incremental language design
uh
language development
series and we have a variety of topics
the first one here is georasta
so
let's take a look
uh do i how do i run geo-rusted do i
have to load in a package oh yeah you
probably need to do needs you know
christopher wolf from backtick georaster
so so for context i mean this is this is
like
a very
prototype thing that i made in the last
few days the summer school
um
and there's lots that's broken about it
but it was sort of a you know
there's some design ideas in it
okay there's a good launch point for
discussion yes
okay so the basic
idea
is supposed to be
that
this is representing
a bunch of essentially pixel values
geopixel values in some sense is that
right so the values could represent you
know population density or they could
represent all kinds of things or they
could be a picture is that is that right
or not yeah basically i mean so it's i
mean technically it's you know it's a
geo-referenced
image so it's an image where it knows
where it is on the earth i think in
terms of like
how we actually think it
you know the data is represented the way
they usually do in remote sensing is
they'll sort of say that um you know
you sort of imagine that there's each
pixel represents a square region
and you know there's a value that's
constant within that square region and
and so on um
so i mean that's basically what this
this represents
and and and just also you know
right so i mean the other thing is that
you know the way that these have been
set up is you know each
each raster it's you know it's a single
you know image with an arbitrary number
of bands
um
you know it also has an alpha channel
and it has
units um but but there's no uh you know
we don't allow things like
you know different units for different
bands or stuff like that for that you
need to have multiple rasters
okay and is that
i mean in in um
okay so if you wanted population density
you want to divide
you know vegetation by vegetation
density by population density or
something you would take two different
rasters in different units divide them
and get out of third rest in the
combined units
is that kind of yeah basically uh you
know i ideally yes i i actually almost
had that exact um
example except the
the website where you download a lot of
those you know geotiffs was broken
earlier today so i i didn't get them but
yes
okay so the concept is
so you're suggesting that image
processing operations could work on
these geo-rasters is that right
well so so this is one of the main
questions i think there there are two
i mean in making this prototype there
were two main sort of things that came
up repeatedly that sort of required you
know
some consistent decision so one of them
was
to what extent geo rasters should
inherit image processing functions and
to an extent they should have their own
functions
um i mean so for example i think it's
it's useful for something like binarize
to work on a geo raster um though it's
there are probably some changes to how
the normal binarize works like the fact
that if we have geo-rasters that can
have units associated with them you'd
like the threshold parameter to be you
know it so could be a quantity which is
a little bit different from a normal
round binaries but then there are other
other operations like you know
i would probably argue something like
pixel value or like image value we
should not have a version of image value
that takes a geo position
right like that would be i think that's
stretching the image
analogy too much
so i mean sort of the the
one of the i think they're different
you know
places we could split it the sort of
general principle i used here was
uh you know on the handful of operations
i i implemented basically if
if the function needs to know about sort
of the projections or geopositions or
just the spherical geometry of the earth
or you know spheroidal geometry of the
earth then it should have its own geo
function and if it's just a blind thing
it's just applying to pixels like
binarize then it should just it should
just work with the image processing
function
all right well let's take a look at some
more stuff here so
um before we go move on i think the the
key question in my mind here is the
relation between your raster and your
image
so for geographics what we did is that
geographics has in the first argument a
graphic subject
but for geoimage for some reason we
didn't go that route
so your image could have been an object
that contains an image in the first
argument and then contains
options
geo options additionally
so i think this is something like
recreating that scenario your raster of
your image because your image returns an
image
is place a role of geographics
around the graphics
but then as far as options that get
stored in the returning image object
there is no additional options that you
support in geoimage well the result i'm
asking is just an image not not a
geoimage object
right that's why
your raster would add the g options like
geographics adds the geo options to
graphics
yes
yeah that makes some sense
so my first question for geo raster is
that what are the options or additional
arguments that geo raster has
that currently image does not have
right so so there's there's two things
so the first thing is in terms of
options it's basically the
geo options so the important ones for
this are uh what is the geo projection
and basically plot range
um
and uh
but now the differences from from uh
uh from from images so i mean the first
thing is i think there's there's a
couple things that are a little
different images like for example
supporting units
um
although i guess we could maybe have
images with units on them but the other
thing is that um there are some cases
where i think i think you know the
semantics have to be different for geo
rasters versus images for example if you
have two geo rasters that say have the
same dimensions but they represent
they're in different projections or they
represent different areas on the earth
if you try and multiply those together i
think that shouldn't work or at least it
should do some it's either fail or to do
reprojection it shouldn't just blindly
multiply things that don't line up um
but of course if they were just had head
image it would have to do that um
so
right in fact we have this very same
problem in show of two geographics
rather than overlaying one on the other
it recomputes a a region of the world
that contains both geographics
okay right
so that was one of the other yes sorry
go ahead the
the plot range problem which is part of
what you're describing here as well has
come up when we have uh come up with um
i think it's called region image
function when we're going from an a
region that could have a different plot
range than
than the typical either zero one zero
one or zero with zero height and we
completely lose it as we convert it to
an image because image does not have
this plot range option in it so that
request has come up there as well
and in many other places like where we
would like to have say a microscopy
image has a sense about what was the
unit
length unit of each pixel so that we
want to know the whole image is so many
nanopixel nanometers times so many
nanometers and then the measurements can
come back in that length measure units
so i think in general
adding plot range to an image object has
been requested in the from different
domains and it's something that is of
interest to the image object in general
geoprojection i think is completely
specific and useful only in this
discussion of georaster's geoimages
units as well however i can see being
of interest for other applications so i
don't think that as well is very unique
to geo
okay but so let's summarize this so
we've also got spherical image coming
which will have its own projection
issues correct
um
but just like an array plot you can give
a data range
that tells you you know what are the
absolute coordinates that this
you know matrix should be placed at
it seems to me that that's not an
unreasonable kind of approach to take
with image
is to have some kind of data range or
something kind of option that specifies
you know how should this be placed in
some absolute coordinate system
right which is similar to how plot range
works in geo
functions
right actually i wasn't i thought it was
geo range it's geo range right yes so
geo range gives you the range where you
give it sort of geographic
you know you'll give it like a geo
position or a geo region and it'll
include that region plot range is in the
coordinates of the of the projection
so if i say you know the projection is
mercator and you know maybe mercator is
0 1 0 1 for the whole earth then i'll
you know those are the coordinates so
is that that and geo grid coordinates
then so that's in is that the geo grid
coordinates
yes there is in fact a geogrid range
which is essentially a synonym of plot
range
so i think
image should be compared to graphics not
to geographics because
graphics already has a plot range which
image does not
yes
another comment about this um
i can imagine another thing we might
want is something where the raw geo
raster has values of i don't know
vegetation levels or something
but that
for the display of this thing we want to
use some particular color map which i
guess we just have it's to be a color
function of some kind
again image object doesn't have a color
function but it has come up enough that
i think yes we should add it as an
option to image so that one can specify
how to color
right i think we even talked about you
know last time we talked about this like
you know a million years ago one of the
things we talked about was
um you know sort of
handling of of images
where they maybe have an arbitrary
number of bands which is something that
we kind of support but there's there's a
few places where
it kind of breaks down a little bit at
least there are cases where for example
it's ambiguous whether the you know the
nth band is the alpha channel or whether
it's just you have an n band image
um
but but i think one of the things we
talked about was having
again this is a while ago but i think we
talked about having some like color
what was it color space or option that
were where you would give it some sort
of matrix and that would sort of tell it
how to linearly combine its its n bands
to produce an rgb
image that makes sense
named colors named channels had come up
in that same discussion as well and then
making up a color function based on
those name channels i think was
discussed again well why on earth with
name channels why isn't that why isn't
that an image data that's an association
i mean as we build these associations
which are these column oriented
associations that should work just fine
i mean right now we might have to have
something that says you know
uh
you know desert level or something
um
but every single one of these for every
single pixel we might need values you
know
um
right i also do think that that for for
geo rasters
i would probably argue so when you get
you know
you know if you if you have like a you
know
what are they called there's like net
cdf files there's geotiff but but some
of them like net cdf they support you
know many layers
um and then they might be in you know
different formats they might be in
different resolutions they might uh you
know they'll have different units and
stuff like that
i i experimented in an earlier version
of this with having like many of those
in one raster
um and this was a bad idea because it
just meant that each raster you know
just had too much stuff in it where for
example you know you couldn't talk about
the resolution of the raster because it
would have you know different
resolutions depending on which layer
you're talking about
so i mean i think i guess we probably
could have near i guess you could near
named bands would still be useful for
doing things like saying this is the red
green you know this is the near infrared
band this is the you know far infrared
band whatever
um
but but i think it's it's probably still
different from
you know the issue of uh of a population
and i have vegetation index
well okay but i it seems to me that in
general as soon as we have column
oriented
um
you know as list association combos
column oriented data set like things
that that will be a good data structure
to use for named bands for image
do we do you agree shoddy do you agree
except that i think each column or quote
unquote column is going to be a 2d array
no i i think the point is that image
data yeah
right well i think the thing is the
problem is the image data you know gives
something where the bands are at the
lowest level right and right now there's
no good way of representing that without
having a bajillion associations which is
horribly inefficient i think the point
is there's been various things like i
know i mean rob knapp has said stuff
about
basically being able to represent
listed associations like that where it's
efficient i mean right which we're about
to get so i mean we can assume that's
coming so there'll be an efficient way
to represent something which is as if
instead of an rgb list at the end it's a
it's an association
and then we can have in the color
function we can have named you know hash
ocean level and things like that
otherwise the color function would by
default would take
um
you know color function would be well
we'd be able to say things like uh
you know well like hash near infrared or
something yeah right right right but
this will be the usual thing with rgb
or or xyz or whatever it is
but then or something with an alpha
channel
um
you know that would be the example
you're writing it would return a
grayscale it would display in greyscale
i suppose that's right right because
otherwise you'd have to have a color
function
which
in
yeah i mean but this actually would be a
wrong thing i mean this would be i like
grayscale gray level of this
yeah
although i do worry a little bit about
efficiency
for well i know like that but yeah
well that's a separate thing being able
to compile that etc etc in the future
blah blah even even now using the
existing compiler would already be
useful for this
but or the name channels thing where
this is
you know
near ir
you know whatever it is for ir whatever
ir
uva
whatever the heck it is
um
okay so you could have the color
function return a list and have it then
use the
you know rgb if you return a triple type
thing
sure
okay but but this is okay let's come
back to the geo raster
so what we're concluding is that image
needs a little bit more annotation
and that
you know one of the issues is given the
data range of two images if two images
have two different data ranges
how do you
what
thing do you have which is the stitching
that
do you get what i'm saying that's
stitching with the actual data range how
would you do that would show do that
maybe image compose or something
would pay attention to the data range
well well so there's a thing actually
maybe okay but a lot more as well
everything like image add image multiply
um
potentially
i think this can go anywhere okay so
you're saying data range arrow automatic
would just place it by pixels and then
it conforms you know it does whatever it
normally does to conform but data ranges
specific data range would cause it to
actually you know take account of that
in doing composition of images
which i think immediately implies that
image should have some kind of a padding
option as well
whether we bought anything
sorry
well this is a one issue i i had an
earlier prototype of the grasser stuff
that basically did this but a little
more extreme because it would do
reprojection so if you for example if
you see these two geo rasters here in
that conform georaster example you see
you know there they are conformed to be
in the same projection same plot range
same resolution
and everything right so they pixel pixel
aligned
but in an earlier version it has they
would automatically if you multiply
those two together it would
automatically conform them and then
and then do that and so on and this led
to all sorts of problems because first
of all um
you don't even know if they're the same
resolution
right and so you don't even know once
you conform them to some common
grid basically you don't even know what
resolution to make that common grid
because maybe that small image you know
maybe the big image is is way lower
resolution in terms of pixels per unit
of data range than the other one and so
you're either going to make some
absolutely massive image or you end up
destroying a bunch of data and it's
really case by case which one you want
to do and very hard to predict at least
when i was
experimenting with this i mean it's even
worse in the geo case because
uh well
yeah it's even worse in the geocache
because you also have the projections
running around and stuff like that but
yeah
right okay so okay so what is your
recommendation here your recommendation
is that they that
by default
so so i listed this is the this was the
the two
core design questions i listed was was
was well two and a half one was was the
thing about automatically
one was the thing about image functions
like should binarize work should you
know image value work the other one was
about this this exact issue so
in an earlier prototype i had like i
mentioned it just did everything
automatically if you multiply two
incompatible things it would pick
something and it would run with it and
so on you pick some common projection
and so on um
in the more room what does image do if
it for example has incompatible color
color spaces or something
depends on the operation
specifically
the thing that i i started looking at
was if the dimensions don't match
because i think that's
that's kind of the same it's basically
the pixels don't line up right i mean
the color spaces you can often do things
like for example multiplying a grayscale
image by an rgb image it's kind of
obvious what to do
but if they're if they're different
dimensions that's the analogous case
where basically they spatially don't
line up so what happens what does it do
some functions um
fail
some functions like image compose
just put one in the center of the other
one
that's pretty random right
and if there was a data range it
wouldn't do that
then it would be hinted to to say what
to do sure
well with image compose doesn't it's
been a while since i've used image
compose that doesn't like compose in
fact it doesn't really require any uh
confirmed images
because it places it you can place them
anywhere right like you can tell it to
place it in some weird positions so it's
kind of what it does but like if you're
multiplying two images it complains that
they have different dimensions
um so i mean to see the the second
version of this the version that i have
in this notebook here basically i have a
function called conform georaster which
is a little bit like conform images
um but but it has some slightly
different usages
um that basically is supposed to make it
easy to get your rasters to pixel pixel
line up
so that you know you can kind of be
responsible for that process instead of
trying to do it automatically so the
main usages were you can give it a list
and then it will try and quote unquote
intelligently pick some common reference
um
you know
right the the other option though
um
was i had it so if you if you give it
you know if you if you if you have two
geo rasters if you give it you know if
you just give it those as separate
arguments it'll conform the first geo
raster to be in the spatial reference to
match the spatial reference of the
second
which i think is useful for
uh
if nothing else i mean because i think
the most common case is they'll have
many different you know
different sources of raster data and
maybe they have different projections
and different geo references and usually
you'll want to pick one as sort of this
is the one that is like my core piece of
data that i want to use i want to
convert everything to the reference
frame of this data
usually because maybe this this one is
the lowest resolution one it's kind of
the important bottleneck and so i don't
want to destroy it anymore by
reprojecting it or something
um
so i you know i think that
just automatically picking something
often inconsistently will probably lead
to weird results so it's better just to
make it easy for people to pick a single
projection
well here i mean this conform images
has kind of a size the second argument
can be either an image to conform to
or purely a size or some other things
correct right
i could imagine it being useful to to
conform something to a geo boundary or
something to a geo bounding box does
that make any sense
yes and then that's kind of what that's
basically what conform geo raster does
but it also conforms for example the
dimensions of the image um like the
raster size um okay fine and else the
projection but but actually one one
other detail just to mention is
i you know there's a there's a an
in-between thing this could easily do
which is instead of just matching
the instead of just matching the images
to be the same dimensions it could just
match them to be the same projection and
the same resolution so that is the same
number of pixels per unit of plot range
or per unit of data range or whatever
um
because then you know as long as you can
get so the grids line up it's
unambiguous how to combine them
um and you don't have to for example do
things like if you see this conformed
image on the right where it's got you
know tons of alpha channel wasting space
um
you know so
yeah
that's effectively what geographics does
when two of them are combined in show
so
the options are preserved but the geo
range is the union of the zero ranges
and the projections and zooms are
forgotten and recomputed
okay so that's a yet different thing
that's a non-conforming thing that's
just the default
that's sure that is a conforming thing i
mean that that is that is basically if
you gave conform your aster a list of g
rasters
that's basically the procedure that it
should follow um i mean picking a common
projection and everything there's some
again there's some complexity about
what's the resolution but but again you
should need some heuristic for that
right so the the images here because
they would have their ongo range would
would play the role of entities it's
like giving a bunch of polygons of
countries and geographics or geoimage or
jio roster would decide what's the best
configuration
okay
all right so let's let's look down at
these design questions
but but one quick point about that is i
think that in most real world usage
usages other than visual other than just
some simple visualization cases you
won't want it to do that because
you know they'll have weird problems
where you know oh i've got these these
you know 100 different images i'm going
to be completing this on and on some of
them maybe it picks this one projection
and others it picks this other
projection
and and you know because one of these is
you know has a projection that distorts
badly in this case you know it's it's
going to destroy a bunch of data and
you're going to get like
you know you're going to get kind of
garbage results so i i worry i mean even
if the heuristics are good about picking
what common projection to use i think
that there's still be cases where you'll
get like inconsistent results
by doing something like that
so okay hold on
actually just
um and hold on one second i'll be right
back just second
i'm sorry yeah okay so
okay so let's let's summarize what are
the questions here
so there's a question of what to do if
you are showing multiple geo-rasters
together is that right
well it's not showing them together it's
about if i want to multiply two
geo-rasters that are in different
projections different resolutions etc
right and you think that should
by default just fail
i think probably it should just fail
because i think that that doing the
reprojection is
you have to make choices that that
that kind of matter
so as the failure basically points
people to conform
geo-raster as probably should be plural
to be like conform images
um
that's probably okay at least at the
beginning
no i mean i guess we could always add
but you know we could always change it
so that maybe we could add auto
projection but we can't get rid of it
yeah
so before we proceed with all of the
design questions are we sure geo raster
is not going to be confusing with geo
image maybe with image with geographics
and all of that
especially with geo image i think they
really sound to be exactly the same
thing
potentially we can ask whether geo image
should return geo raster or geo image
should return a geo image
with all the additional useful options
but i really think having them side by
side might end up being confusing well
look right now geo image returns an
image yes
and changing that will probably break
things unfortunately
i mean i i think it's yeah i agree i
think it is it is very confusing um but
it's sort of unfortunate because i i
mean i don't really know
i i predict it would break things if we
started returning a different kind of
object well
image
look if geo image returns a geo image so
to speak and image processing works on
it then probably nobody will even notice
it isn't an image maybe but for example
just just you know
maybe this is a weird case but if people
say get different geo images let's say i
wrote a program that that gets different
images of the same resolution you know
for lots of different areas and i don't
know it sort of you know fades them on
top of each other that will fail with
you know any kind of geo-rastery thing
um which should complain about such an
operation
so i mean i think the the the kind of
lame excuse
i was making for for why it should why
georaster could be a separate thing
although i acknowledge this is a lame
excuse and that it's it'd still be very
confusing is that you know geo raster
could in some ways be similar to how
raster is versus image
although arguably raster maybe shouldn't
even exist anymore but but basically the
argument being that you know raster is
like a graphics primitive
you know that you can put directly into
graphics and presumably georaster one of
the nice things you'd want to be able to
do with it is to feed it into
geographics and have it to show up as
though it was sort of a graphics
primitive but but obviously this kind of
breaks down because you don't run
binaries on a raster object but
yes
well maybe you shouldn't be running
banner eyes on a geo raster either
i mean maybe that was i think it would
be pretty useful but yeah
well
i mean it could work as a courtesy
but
well generally if you want to run in
image processing operations turn it into
an image
so how would you turn a geo raster into
a plain old image
um so i had a couple ways i mean one one
is and i had some accessor thing where
you can just say of quotes image but i
think probably the better thing is
well maybe the better thing is i have
this thing geo what is it called geo
raster data that's kind of an analog of
image data but it does more stuff
because it needs to so for example you
know image data normally just gives you
the pixel values but you know the idea
is geo raster data would give you things
like the pixel values but it could also
give you for example the areas of the
different pixels right because if you're
not using equal area projection each
pixel might represent a different area
or it can give you the pixel values as a
weighted data object where they're
weighted by the areas
which is something that you know
there are a lot of remote sensing papers
and software that does not do this which
is kind of crazy because they make
histograms of pixel values over large
areas where the pixel sizes are
radically different in different parts
of the raster but
right so i mean
you know this sort of thing um but one
of the ideas i mean geo raster data if
it's returning all these different kinds
of things could also easily have an
image property that could give you
you know though i think just image of
geo raster should probably work
or maybe it's geo image of geo raster
oh my god so we'll have geo image of geo
raster joe image
why would you put a geo image inside the
juror you'd have to tell the geo image
what part of the earth it corresponds to
and things well
right right i mean i did the the reason
you'd have the um
right i mean some of these examples what
i do is i if you have a
so geo image returns images but it
actually has
metadata about where the image is it has
a spatial reference and so one of the
kind of bridging things i had at least
in this prototype was if you give
georaster one of these images that has a
spatial reference it will use it and
turn it into a geomaster so you can
actually run georaster of joe image
that's on the basis of this idea of
basically adding to image some metadata
well imagine the point the images
produced by geo geo image already have
that metadata
but it's not it's not used anywhere i
mean it's just it's just kind of in the
it's in the meta information option
the plan there was that we would be able
to
insert any of these images inside
geographics and it would appear
immediately
it can be done because the
the there is enough information already
there
if you ask for
meta information of this
can i just say measure information of
that
i think there's no options for that
information
yeah
there you go geo meta information
wow i don't even think this is
documented anywhere but i could be wrong
no it's not because it's not used yet
anywhere
so you see how there is the the proper
geo information the long lock box and
the plot range the plot range could be
moved to the image itself it's what you
were calling data range before but the
london box is
is purely
and then the projection and the
projection exactly
addition to the image object adding it
to the object is easy but properly
working with it in all the 200 and
something functions we have is going to
be a huge project
all right right yeah but i mean that
will get slowly done hopefully sure
um
okay so i mean i guess it's a similar
thing for something like units
i was even wondering i mean for units
when i was playing around with this
because
there's there's behavior with units it's
very unclear what it should do
like like you know i started by just
saying oh i'm gonna kind of i mean i
didn't implement anything too serious
but i was like i'm gonna vaguely emulate
um
uh quantity array um but then there's
stuff like if you run log of a quantity
array i mean log of you know log meters
is not a unit that i think we can really
you know handle right now and so what uh
you know if you run log of a quantity it
just returns unevaluated log of quantity
of law
and so the the quantity array if you're
on log of a quantity array turns into a
list of log of quantity of laws but
there's of course you can't do that
behavior with an image so i guess you'd
maybe return an unevaluated log of image
thing or i don't know i
there's all sorts of uh messiness there
okay but i think it is clearly useful to
have
values in an image or at least a geo
raster be united
so really that
so something related to that and
something that i miss frequently in
images is that
sometimes for example in an elevation
profiles there is some sort of hole
value
these elevations are typically given in
between minus 30 2000 and plus 32 000 in
meters and when there is a hole they
just assigned value minus 32 000
but this is inconvenient when inserted
in image because it rescale everything
and then everything becomes black for
example just because because that value
is there so it would be great to have a
some sort of
background value or something like that
in image such that that value is not
used for
visualization
there's actually two two different
the i i had two different versions of
those that i was i was playing around
with geomaster so one is exactly that
the fill values
you can at least get the behavior of
fill values although maybe not the
efficiency of it by having an alpha
channel um
so you know
we can kind of do that semantics right
now but again again it's not as
efficient um although if if a lot of geo
rasters have alpha channels because
they've been reprojected and they're no
longer even rectangular or something
like that then it's kind of free to then
maybe you know
include holes in the alpha channel the
other one though and this is again just
sort of an efficiency thing um
is
uh
oftentimes you'll get one of these
rasters and it'll say something like
okay this is a you know what do we call
it bit 16 image that's between 0 and 65
you know 65536 or whatever it is um
and uh but then you'll be told that okay
this is in units of meters and and you
know zero corresponds with minus one
thousand meters and sixty-five thousand
corresponds with you know
uh
twelve thousand meters or something like
that and you're just expected to kind of
linearly interpolate
um
and and that's you know right now the
only way we can deal with that is by
just saying okay well i'm not going to
really represent the images of bit 16.
i'm going to rescale the whole image and
represent it as some real 32 or
something like that but that can often
sort of destroy data a bit and it can
sort of uh and of course it means that
the image isn't you know it's using
twice the memory and stuff like that um
so
that's another similar kind of
thing
why aren't we using this you know data
framish type technology
to be
you know
you've got the raw image inside or the
raw raster inside
and then all this stuff about providing
units and this and that and the other
why isn't that in this framing
wrapper which is kind of maybe more or
less what geo raster is
we do have planar images already
supported which means instead of having
the rgb or channel 1 channel 2
vectors
listed in the image raster we can have
all of channel 1 then all of channel 2
and so forth and we do handle processing
planar images as efficiently as in
interleaved images
yes the interleaving option it's just
that we don't we haven't named those
channels yet
or haven't haven't or haven't given
those channels any unit or
or any specific description of any sort
what do we need to do to move this
forward
making all the upgrades to the image
object or the geo raster moving jewelry
i think i think moving geo raster
forward is the low hanging fruit of
functionality
but you know putting these additional
things into image
is a longer term play but one that we
should at least understand when we're
designing geo raster
right so maybe the thing to do i mean
because right i was going to say it
sounds like you know if we want all the
things we want in geo raster
probably you know
it's sort of it probably wants to
inherit a lot of that functionality from
images so maybe the thing to do is to
kind of you know
have a geo-raster that's a bit
impoverished i mean maybe for example it
doesn't
maybe it doesn't uh it doesn't know
about units and stuff like that but
that's sort of whenever images
start to be able to to handle units then
geo raster will kind of inherit that
that's awesome as opposed to because
otherwise implementing you know image
operations you know
for geo-raster where g-raster can have
units is going to be the same exact work
but but done in a more bootleg fashion
than if images just supported units
themselves
right
so shoddy i mean that that to me
i would assume that those are specified
by options things like units in images
will be specified by options
yep
so we should probably design that so
that's kind of the next thing so geo
raster without images leveraging sorry
without units and things leveraging
images
but the only
additional services that geo raster
would have is geo
positioning so to speak which it has to
your projection and then maybe maybe
data range plot range whatever it's
called grid range
yes those two things
and i mean clearly images fairly soon
would have to start wheeling in data
range or whatever it's going to be
called
um but
geo raster has to have that from the
beginning because otherwise it's useless
now i don't quite understand when when
you if you want to find the area of
black pixels or something
in a geo raster
how how would you do that
okay so i i
i hadn't thought of that use case but
there's an easy way to do it so um i
mean say you've you've finalized your
image and now you've got you know the
black and white pixels
so um i think the easiest way to do it
is i had a usage of
joe well okay
i'll phrase it one way and then there's
another way it could work but basically
geo raster data you'd be able to give it
uh or okay geo value is really the other
function which is like image value and
basically but maybe could be used for
other things as well
but basically the idea would be that you
could give it something like a polygon
it will give you you know the value of
all the pixels in that polygon just like
what pixel value does but but you know
but you could also like pixel value give
it a mask so you'd give it this black
white mask and then uh you'd request
instead of the pixel values you'd
request the pixel areas and then you'd
maybe total those
yes
i i want to mention the fact that
geographics is very powerful already in
manipulating images so in a sense
what your raster is going to be doing
may be already implemented in
geographics geographics can
reproject images
can find things there is even internally
a geo image transformation function
right
even in this prototype i'm using i'm
calling that exact function yeah like
yes
this is doing no heavy
lifting okay
all right so what else do we need to
know to move this forward
so i think the other question was the
what this does in terms of binarize of
this and so on
and it sounded to me like there's a
certain set of image processing
functions
that by the way are probably the same
set
that don't have to worry about
uh
any conforming of anything
kind of unary operations
that i'm guessing could work here
yeah like edge detect and
binarize
there's some like i think we talked
about a while ago that there's some that
are kind of weird edge cases almost them
i don't i can't really imagine
where you'd want this but like for
example blur because blur is something
that is you could easily apply blur to
any image you don't need to know about
the joe reference or anything like that
but
you know
you know the blur radius
you are getting quote-unquote the wrong
answer in the sense that you know if i
had a geoprojection if i had a giraffe
and i blurred it and uh you know it
blurred the north pole with the same
radius that blurred the equator in some
projection where the north pole has been
way inflated it's quote-unquote going to
get the wrong answer that it didn't
apply the radius consistently i don't
know why anyone would care about this
like i care about blurring a g raster
anyway but but there's some cases like
that where it's kind of like if the
function were being super super official
and quote unquote correct it would have
to take into account geo stuff but in
practice it probably doesn't have to so
there are some weird cases like that
right but but then i mean the
the basic concept would be initially
that there's an up well there's an up
value for various image processing
functions
that make them work on geo rasters
right
on a random technical level they
probably eventually have to not be up
values because if they are up values so
this is this is a random note but like a
lot of the functions like for example
multiply if they fail on images they
return unevaluated or maybe multiply a
bad example functions like i think
binarize even if you you can in some
cases return unevaluated um
but uh but then of course if you do that
with a geo raster
and uh you return on evaluate it's just
going to go back to the image
implementation and and uh you know but
that's a random technical detail
all right well this is looking nice i
mean so okay let's should we move on
okay let's talk about our next topic
outliers for plot
so my basic issue is when there is a
value that is out of range
you have no indication of that
in the displayed plot
i think this is wrong
i think you should have a little
you know there should be a marker like
this that is a little you know carrot or
something up here that's like a a i'm
off-scale
kind of uh
you know
plot marker
does that make any sense
i mean it makes sense i mean you know at
some level it's you know implementing
clipping style for list plots
you know i mean i don't know how
specific this is to list plot versus
other viz functions or no i think it's
it's a clipping style story i mean look
it is a problem
okay if this was a uh um
if that was this line plot yeah then it
wouldn't be a problem
well it's less of a problem i think it's
still maybe a little bit of a problem
that's something you could imagine
you can imagine i mean for example you
know people put little you know dashed
lines and an arrow at the end
you know where it goes off right like if
you say clipping style goes to dashed on
that list line plots
right that does something pretty nice
like this
that's very
nice that's magnificent actually i
didn't even know that worked
that's magnificent
so yeah so i think what i'm asking for
then is a as an analog of this for dots
but
pure
you know discrete marker type things
gotcha and you i think so i watched the
recording from when you guys discussed
this while i was on break
um and you were also saying sort of in
the corners for
you know completely out of range stuff
yes
yes i mean
well i guess there's a question even
with graphics
if you have stuff that is just not in
the plot range what do you do
i think graphics should be totally
mechanical and shouldn't do anything
clever like this okay i mean what was
that what was the only thing that comes
with axes or something or a frame
right i mean
can you can you switch this to a frame
real quick
yeah
lily do we have jeremy here
i'm here i am
i still don't know how you would apply
this to a giant set of points that are
clipped
i mean maybe one option would be to
i mean this is a little bit different
from how the clipping style works with
the lines but you could do something
like
somehow annotate the whole
you know side of the frame like i don't
know if you imagine having a dashed you
know the right edge is dashed because
there's random there's points that are
being emitted that are off the right
edge yeah i'm not sure how clear it is
okay so that's what that does
and so i'm just wondering you know sort
of
you know in the case where stuff is
outside of that rectangle
i
think so we know which side it's on i
think it should just be a little grayed
i don't know what arrowy type thing
they're just gonna place the oh on the
top at the top there and if it was if it
was a negative value it'd be down at the
bottom here
do you think maybe it could even be
placed i don't know about the accident
axis case but maybe if it's a frame it
could maybe be placed outside of the
frame
we don't want anything outside the frame
look this one isn't outside the frame
if it was placed in the same place that
this is right here it will be just fine
the thing i'm worried about is that when
you have point when you have lines you
can tell when a you know a dashed line
is not a line
but but if you have points pretty much
i'm not suggesting
even a different marker i'm a little
worried that it's going to
look similar and we even have stuff i
mean
i mean i'm thinking a little bit like
geo list plot or sorry uh yeah geo list
plot which of course has different
markers for different things and i i
yeah i think it would have to be an out
of range marker which is grayed down and
has a sort of arrowy appearance
that's what i would suggest so that this
go ahead is this for only for plot range
automatic when you didn't specify like
if you specify a plot range i assume
this doesn't happen
i assume it doesn't happen but i assume
you can ask what do you mean it doesn't
happen i mean like if you take that less
line plot and you say plot range goes to
zero to ten
i would sure hope that it still draws
the dotted line at the top
i think this was discussed last time and
last time
the the last time i i agree that that
makes sense but last time i think we
came to the opposite conclusion which
isn't a great sign but what if the x
range was to a thousand right but you're
only showing one to ten and it's going
up in a ramp are you going to show 900
dots
potentially
i that's what
what i would expect jeremy is that
if you have 900 points off the top that
are between whose x values
are between 0 and 10
then the top edge is going to be dense
with missing things yeah that's what i
would think too if you've got a hundred
things that are
you know off in the quadrant you know
kitty corner to
you know one of those rectangles
that there's one marker representing
them all
so
okay a basic question what is the
default behavior like do you have to ask
for this
initially yes but we might change that
okay because i think if you have to ask
for this i think it's fine i think if
you if it happened automatically though
i'd be really worried about
having weird gray dots appearing kind of
out of nowhere especially because like
for example if you set the plot range
explicitly
it's very common you know you'll have a
bajillion points and you just want to
display this little area
like a finance graph where you've got a
time window it's you know you don't
always want to see everything or even
know about the rest
exactly yeah a fair point fine but
that's the same thing as clipping style
well the default is clipping style is
none right
right so we'll turn it on with clipping
style
and
you know we may need some little control
for what the marker looks like or
something but i think so but the case
that we were talking about here so one
case is
x is within range y is not
and y is within range x is not those are
both straightforward now the case is
both x and y are out of range
that means it's a corner it's in a
corner right
and that may look a bit obscure
would it be enough to have an indication
that not all the data is included
and without indication of what it is
no i think in the case where in this
case here it's very nice to be able to
have the little dots at the top
i think the case where it is uh you know
a corner case where both x and y are too
large
i could imagine just omitting that case
or having some other option to turn it
on because i think it's just going to
look weird
why not just have a single marker in the
corner we could do that but what's it's
going to be i mean we can try it we can
try it
it's going to look like it's
representing the corner of the plot as
opposed to representing it something is
missing no i'm i'm so it's got to be a
rotated angle a arrow head that would be
like at 45 degrees there
i just think it should look like a
little piece of random detritus and
nobody's going to know what it is
well i think that or
down in the bottom left corner where
your axes are congregating or something
yeah by the way it reminds me of the
fact that i would in some cases
yeah that's kind of a stupid thing to
say i was gonna say you know showing
that this doesn't go to zero on these
axes
seems like a thing because a lot of
times in a lot of images a lot of
you know things you'd have a a broken
you know a dash dashboard
some sort of indicator that the actual
correct
we should we should have at least an
option to produce that
and i i think we have some ideas on how
to do that these days um so we may intro
sooner than later but i think the thing
that we are immediately talking about is
the out of range clipping style for
points
okay we've got a clipping style for
lines we've got a clipping style i would
imagine for surfaces
let's just have a a i mean if i say
uh list plot 3d
do plot 3d it's easier
you know one over
you know x squared plus y squared or
whatever
i don't think you want dashed
i know
i was just curious what it would do it
did something i'm curious what it filled
that in with
because by default it leaves a hole
there
so
i don't know what it did you couldn't
investigate what it did
okay
do we have a 3d analog of dashed like
like i don't even know what that would
be well we haven't been like hedge
filling
except that hatchfield is a 2d primitive
well so even though it looks like a 2d
thing that we should be able to
yeah what we should we should the fact
this doesn't work is unfortunate what's
the 3d thing that we call what is that
3d thing called um try like stipple
shading or something
that's the one that i that comes to mind
most quickly
whoa
magnificent
what's the design i don't know if it's
coming through on zoom but it looks like
it's it's like a portal to another
dimension like the stipples aren't
moving as you rotate it right
yes stipples are stationary
yes that is how that works
um
that's kind of nice we should have an
example of that
that is yeah i've never tried that
before so
i think there's something better than
stipple shading though what what is that
toon shading
the tune shading is going to be boring
because it's a flat surface
what's the other kind of shading that is
more like cross hatching
well that's a texture why you just do
question mark star shading
hat shading
oh you did hatch filling last time
right
it ends up looking about the same or
something
it does it just looks like
it has some options but it just looks
like
it looks like a piece of a meteorite
that's been chopped off with metal
grains or something
okay
well anyway we should add that to the
examples for clipping style and so on
kind of a nice case
uh
and also for hat shading
but
be this as it may i mean what we're
looking for is something where even in
the 3d case if it's points
there should be a way of displaying that
point as a little gray arrowheady type
thing i think by default
yeah that makes sense
but so do we try to do that for every
missing point or clipped point
yeah some limit okay i mean every
clipped point that
is you know
like
either the x or y component would be in
range
we're not going to draw a thousand
markers for the things that are off
right because we'll be in the same place
the corner case yeah right right
literally literally exactly yeah
um
okay so we're going to need a
two things we're going to need the
the markers we're going to need you know
sort of markers in every coordinate
direction which we probably can get by
just rotating a given marker exactly
i was thinking you know we'd specify a
marker and it would just rotate it
to point whatever direction it needed i
think so but then the corner case
probably should be separately specified
all right so let's get some experiments
on this okay
and there's no other functions that this
affects i mean like geo list plot
i guess it will be the same thing it
could be a corner marker oh not a
quantum marker i mean strictly speaking
geo list plot you
know you could put it anywhere and it's
off that way somewhere
yes
um i mean you know it's the typically
comes up with something like discrete
plot or you know something but
um
but i mean there's
not that many point generators
yes
yes yeah what would you do if it was a
projection that was that's only defined
on a part of the earth and the point is
outside that projection
what does geo bearing do in that case
what's your direction
you give those jewels that doesn't
matter because those are on the earth
yeah
this is an edge case of an edge case
though so i mean yeah i understand
that's what the geography it's the point
case
the boundary of the right right
um
okay all right let's go quickly talking
of such things compass point
so this is something that originally
spawned a bit because there was a
somewhat popular resource function
basically you give it an angle on a
compass and it will give you a cardinal
direction string
we have the inverse functionality
already in some geo functions
which is what
um so if we expand the the two sections
down there we can basically
so geo destination you can say i want to
go 300 kilometers northwest by north and
it knows that direction corresponds to
326 and a quarter degrees
but we don't have a system function that
does any translation between these
so it's basically a
feature that allows us to specify a
direction
with these strings but it's not
thoroughly documented
well you might as well have this as an
exposed thing i don't see any reason not
to
so what would it be called
would we have both directions like two
compass point from compass point i think
so just like we have from you know
hours minutes seconds right degrees yeah
dms strings
yeah what is it called
uh from dms
i think
from dms is
the heck is that
um that's five degrees six minutes six
seconds convert it into a device
into degrees
exactly
okay
and so if i say dms string
okay i get that so
in other words cardinal direction string
would be the obvious thing if i say
cardinal direction string of
280 or something or 270 i should get
east
is that right
uh east is 90. so this
is sorry sorry sorry sorry yes right
sorry i'm
yes
are there different formats for these by
the way
yes or is there one standard way of
doing this well i think we should
support both the e and the east
right so one can write uh east
or
there and uh
in in the geo destination competition
and it works too
so i think is that documented by the way
sorry
your displacement has many examples well
a collection of examples for example the
the winds there is also the tradition of
naming the cardinal directions by names
of winds zero
um what is this
dms string of ns
yes so the idea there is that one can
say i have a number and i want to return
yeah it's not
north i see so so it's like such and
such a dms string
of
280
east west
[Music]
whereas if you said minus 280 then
you'd presumably get
right yes
okay so we've already got very nearby
functionality
okay can you open the page of geo
displacement
and look at the
first so that was just outrageously slow
that look up there
actually not the first
scroll down please
perhaps the last
sorry
um no
sorry forgotten which one it is
one of those examples documents the
various names
i think you went past it
there
yeah here
yeah exactly
okay so those things should all be
string types just like with integer name
and so on we have certain named types
on output you should be able to get
abbreviated or not abbreviated or
right
right and you see at the at the end one
of the examples of our wind look at this
what happened to my screen there
something has eaten it
on the blanket
yeah do you see that through zoom yeah
yeah it's a power saving thing
i mean it's a power saving
that doesn't want to light up all those
pixels
um
by the way sander is commenting that
there is a generalized dms string
function in the function repository
let's take a look at that
uh
one second
um
why is this not working
sorry
uh
um
oh i will have it
okay
um
that's what i wanted
ah by sander himself okay
what does this do
um
wow all kinds of cool stuff here
well this is something we need to look
at i we can't cover it right now
but um
um
okay i unfortunately need to run off um
but okay let's let's pick it up next
time and remember sanders interesting
functional repository entry here looks
very nice
all right i should go okay see you guys
soon